hot surfaces and liquids don't mix
drop water on a really hot surface and
instead of evaporating the droplets
start to skitter around
this is called the leidenfrost effect
and it can be a problem if you're trying
to use water to cool down systems prone
to overheating
that's why zuang kai wang and his
colleagues in hong kong have found a
clever way to get rid of the leidenfrost
effect and create a surface that water
will evaporate from instead of bouncing
off
[Music]
the landing force effect is a classical
physical
phenomena
first observed in
1756 by a doctor named lady frost this
physical phenomenon isn't just confined
to the lab actually this kind of thing i
mean it's very ordinary in everywhere
for example in the kitchen bouncing
water droplets let cooks know that their
pan is up to temperature
in this case that temperature known as
the leidenfrost point is around 200
degrees celsius
below this point the water just starts
to boil and evaporate away if the water
plate will evaporate very quickly that
means that the surface temperature is
not at a high i think below 200 degree
but above this point something strange
happens
when a water droplet hits the pan the
bottom of it evaporates instantly
turning into vapor
this water vapor forms a cushion under
the droplet that it can slide around on
it also acts as a kind of insulating
barrier because the rest of the droplet
isn't in direct contact with the pan and
so doesn't evaporate as quickly
bouncing water droplets and a lack of
efficient evaporation can be a problem
liquid-based cooling systems in things
like manufacturing and nuclear power
plants depend on evaporation to get rid
of excess heat so scientists have been
looking for ways to get rid of this
insulating layer so this is a challenge
occurred over the past 200 years you
know how to break the lighting frost
effect
and various solutions have been put
forward for example a grooved textured
surface helps stop the vapor layer from
forming and keeps the liquid in contact
with the hot material but this only
works up to a point so far the highest
like the first point
is around 500 degree no one has been
able to stop the leidenfrost effect
happening at extremely high temperatures
until now
zuankai and his team have developed what
they call a structured thermal armor
the new design includes a special
membrane embedded in the channels which
wicks the water down into the grooves
the membrane can suck the water
very efficiently so when the water
contacts the membrane the water is
absorbed
and then spread on the surface and then
become evaporated the combination of the
texture and the absorbent membrane stops
the droplets from bouncing off and helps
the liquid evaporate so it can
efficiently cool down the hot surface
so how hot can this new technique go
actually that limit for uh there's no
limit because on our armor we couldn't
see the lighting froze in fact
during testing their structured thermal
armor reached 1200 degrees celsius
without any bouncing droplets but at
that point the steel it was made from
started to melt
zwonkai thinks with different materials
it could get even hotter
and the flexible armor could be used in
a range of cooling applications for
example in nuclear power plant right we
want to remove the heat at high
temperature
and also in turbine the engine right or
any aircraft
the current approach is not that
efficient
so think about your one day
we can replace
the current material without our armor
and then you can just spread the water
on armor and suddenly
the temperature will drop